okay I tried all right and we're live
what's going on guys this is Rob and
Benny's not here
Benny is taking a break he's off doing
his own Benny stuff whatever that
happens to be so in replacement of Benny
we've brought in Joel
so Benny like you'd never be here again
I could be loud it'd make sure people
don't get words in edgewise oh man so
anyway um so initially we were just
gonna talk about like spider-verse of
the orders of the weekly pool but now
that we have Joel here um should talk
about whatever like yeah which we just
learned and we were just kind of talk
about whatever Joel asked the question
if we were anything interesting this
week and and I read New Avengers number
30 I have been I've been actively
avoiding everything to do with the
incursions oh I'm I'm I'm full in for
battle world and Secret Wars and
everything but like I feel like yes
we're getting it you know what I'm
basically on train waiting here's my
thing I got a bunch of them digitally
and I am waiting on if I didn't have to
review stuff every week I would have
gotten it through I'm waiting on it and
it's like it keeps getting closer and
closer my I gotta start this like
tomorrow on up in time is what I'm
waiting for things to be like time runs
out like once it gets closer like like a
week before like sicker war starts you
know like all right guys like the trade
comes out next Wednesday able to be like
hi guys let's do Tom runs out is the
thing to like I always wait for Hickman
like his uh uncanny Avengers run arrived
the one that took like what was like two
real world years to finish one story or
something
mm-hmm like I waited on that and I'm
just like we was seeing the lead-up to
accent like you don't I'll wait and I'll
read the whole thing and I sat down for
a couple nights and I'm like that was
nice I'm glad I didn't have to wait for
any of that that validates my
decision-making when it comes to
Hickman's run entirely cuz I actively
picked up New Avengers like when at
first when it RiRi launched for volume
three with the Illuminati as the New
Avengers I was like oh
cool and Steve Epting was drawing it I'm
like this book rocks and it went like so
dark so fast and I dealt with I I
tolerated the Black Swan and I dealt
with the world builders and all that
crap and then infinity came out and it
was horrible
oh no see here's a cool thing like off
like all the incursian tie-ins for
infinity just ignore infinity the the
core infinity boy every part of infinity
that was core was hardcore awesome Thor
kneeling to the Builder and then get the
and like putting a tee in a friggin
builders chest creating Avengers worlds
were like the Kree are like indebted to
earth because the Avengers rescued them
from annihilation like everything about
infinity that didn't take place on earth
was effing awesome everything else was
on was intolerable and like I remember
we were gonna do infinity on back issues
and I picked up the trade and it's this
thick and it has all the tie ins in it
and I'm like what are you doing you're
forcing me to read these tie-ins I just
won't do it like forget it
I wanted to read the core book and go no
screw the tie-ins guys we're just gonna
talk about how awesome this book is and
how and how many ending is and I won't
spoil that necessarily unless we want to
but like meh that innit
I actually think we skipped a lot of the
tie-ins over on comic book cast for
infinities cuz no one was really
interested what's like hey guys you got
a got a shiny new tie and here you want
to do it yeah like all right so so
Hickman's been doing this since like
2011 right he's been doing it for like
two and a half three years or something
like that hey this is amazing he moves
at a slow pace he moves at a snail's
pace when it comes from okay I would
call him glacial yeah I know her I would
call him glacial but that would be an
insult to most glaciers I know that's
why I love hickman like like I agree
hickory moves like the continents float
but I think his stories because they're
so slow like I think they're amazing
like the only downside I would say to
this is that after three years
it's just now getting to a like holy Sh
well that's no burn and it's really
awesome like if you're playing the long
game it's kind of Awesome yeah is it
worth the wait though having heard yeah
well I skipped after they after they
blew up the third earth and I saw that
it wasn't gonna end until 2015
I was like I think I can skip this until
2015 and damned if I'm right because
they blew up like what 12 more earths
and had a bunch of fights that didn't
matter between then and I mean like
didn't matter if you enjoyed it we had
fun reading it like then I guess it did
matter but like Doctor Strange selling
his soul and then being like you don't
have a soul to sell Stephen straight
like okay alright can we just have
Doctor Strange be cool and have cool
stuff happen don't worry he will right
around the time the movie comes along
cool you know it'll all be good as long
as they read as long as they they tap
Brian cave on and have him do a sequel
to the oh yeah then I think who everyone
will be happy because they'll be like oh
this is a duck stage book I can freaking
read cuz like I love Doctor Strange he's
freaking awesome and he's like the 70s
version Doctor Strange where he's like
he's like a psychedelic trip like
old-school TV and he's just like well
I'm not even gonna be near Earth for the
next six issues because I'm in the Dark
Dimension and it's like written like
like somebody trying to channel
Lovecraft but it's they're not quite as
good as Lovecraft it just sounds really
ridiculous
that's cool I prefer um like doctor like
Sherlock Holmes Doctor Strange oh that's
a fun version you know like here's a
problem with Doctor Strange like his
character is dumb his character is not
dumb this piece of plastic here's a
great origin has a great origin top top
10 best oranges and calm origins and
complete dr. house doctor that's exactly
it like he was an [ __ ] who got into a
car wreck and burgers hands so okay
became sorcerer supreme okay okay fine
then tell me alert
along the way tell me a story with
doctor strings that you can make
captivating this the oath okay no the
oath member like a classic Doctor
Strange story give me a like give me
like a give me a doctor strange story
but you can whip up that'll just be
intriguing and bees and anybody could be
like oh my god this is just one of the
greatest stories ever written dr.
strange doctor do
nobody can do oh that's okay that's
cheering dr. doom is a good character I
think I mean Yolo drew it I'm gonna look
that up
yes he did haha it was written by Roger
the badass book greatness dr. strange
that doesn't count what Doctor Doom
carries the story no Doctor Strange is
Doctor Doom is a catalyst for the story
doctor string we're reading the book dr.
strange to me it's just cool that dr.
doom was also I wasn't really like
wicked he come to dr. strange for help
and he'd be like how do I magic then
this was saying this is we're going back
I guess almost 10 years when the New
Avengers were formed by Bendis and Mark
Miller's like I don't have any I can't
use dr. strange in my civil war story
because he'll just use magic and make it
go away so he goes on a hunger strike
weak and dumb and then after the Civil
War breaks is over and cap dies dr.
strange is all like I feel bad that I
did that hunger strike I'm gonna join
the New Avengers which everyone lost
their [ __ ] over in myself included and
then he's like I'm not worthy of being
the sorcerer supreme i lured up so many
times and my role in world war hulk was
horribly mismanaged so you know i guess
i'll just wear a trench coat and like
complain for the next two years
it works for john it was dr. Constantine
it was totally we except if dr. strange
d-pad or D supreme was Constantine like
was like a Hellblazer book that would
have been freaking awesome
they haven't tried to go that direction
but then again the Constitution show
hasn't been doing so hot hashtag save
Constantine all over Twitter Levine was
carrying that drug yeah Oh cuz he loved
the show he dropped down halfway through
and he knew it wasn't gonna make he's
like no no no this is another being
human I'm not gonna get into video and
love it then they're gonna take it away
from me
yeah I don't think he watched the finale
I did no you were right by the way
because like I watched the pilot for
this actually we're gonna talk about the
plot in the pilot and I was like okay
and TIFF and I watched it we were like
this is baller it's gonna get cancelled
because it was like cuz it wasn't on ABC
which means like you know it wasn't and
it wasn't on sci-fi which means it's not
gonna get a second season and that's
just that's just the nature of the beast
so like I was like I can't I can't I
can't back you John I'm sorry I can't
love this I can't fall in nope with this
that's the kid mm-hmm Firefly is ruined
television for me little bit you know
what sucked to about Constantine it's
the fact that that Hellblazer comic is
so like influential that so many other
goddamn shows stole Constantine's
Thunder before he even made it to
television it's a John Carter situation
it's true yeah by the way that movie was
cool that was a dope movie I'm gonna say
no no sir
John Scott no John Carter of Mars was a
cool movie no my dog crap no and there
was there was never a point in the story
of John why do you think it tanked so
bad it's considered one of the words yes
nobody wants because a was horribly
marketed B who's Taylor Kitsch or
whoever plays can I tell you who he is
he's three strikes and he's out Taylor
yeah but no like no I dug the crap out
of John out of John Carter and because
they were so worried about it failing
they infuse so much more money into it
that all the CG looks even better than
it would have if they had just had
confidence in it so it looks even better
Willem Dafoe does such a great job with
that digital character like know the
whole movies really cool
it's fun I really dug that movie it's
three hours long yeah I didn't like it
oh man yeah yeah I got you know I didn't
but it but anyway so back on game
incursions um no no so so like basically
like with issue number 30 this is where
you could see it like it's gonna take
off now
like Hickman's been building up and it's
like at this point now where it's just
and [ __ ] just takes off like this is the
top of the hill on the roller coaster
that took three years to get up to yeah
that's that's what I'm really digging
about it because now Hank comes back and
the beyonders are here and it's like oh
my god like everything is going
absolutely crazy and basically he's like
we have no chance there's nothing we can
do they killed the Living Tribunal I
tried you know the universe and a half
that's pretty much just like it's like
the writers it's like they know they
know the universe is gonna change and be
reset so let's have as much fun as but
let's flip every table let's burn a big
down well we can yeah they burn that
used to the ground man like like it was
it was so cool because I I didn't really
like I was I was going through like I
was flipping through the pages and I was
reading it and hank pym is like well
let's just go with you I was trying to
find where boom allall and I couldn't
find him and I was trying to go to I was
going to all these realities and it's
like oh my god like like the beyonders
and the mapmakers and like the beyonders
or like the ivory kings or like they're
killing everything off the map makers
are like trying to stop them and then
like the ex nihilo is whatever the [ __ ]
they are like the organic than that yeah
they're working with the map makers and
it's just like okay whatever and so um I
just get to the point where it makes
sense and I flipped the next page and
like the B honors are killing everything
and I'm like oh my god can we talk
really quick about the beyonders what
like I know what the Beyonder was but
all three times they retconned him yeah
there are multiple beyonders yes there
always been multiple beyonders has that
always been the case or that had always
been the case as far as Avengers number
40 goes like there have always been
Michael being under the ladder well I
mean no not okay not multiple beyonders
in terms of like the guy that bang
hookers beyonders like there was that
there was like the one beyond her yeah
like that's not what
we showed up in a secret jheri-curl
Beyonder yeah jerry crow beyonder looked
like john travolta anyway and and anyway
so what point along the line like when
they read condom basically in and secret
wars - mm-hmm and they said well the
cosmically no i'm so it wasn't super
worst yeah we see course - when they
said he was a cube yeah no no no no i
wasn't secret worse - that was a
fantastic for number something or other
all right um but anyway yeah so anyway
and what's a rec on dat the Beyonder
they said that the Beyonder was a
mistake that what had happened was they
make cosmic hues by opening like tearing
holes to the negative zone to little
packets of energy and then it was
supposed to funnel in and then you're
supposed to make a key bat of it but
that didn't happen like what molecule
man got his powers he tore up and a hold
of this power he got half of this power
from it and then the other half the
power turned into the Beyonder which is
why they were able to fight on an equal
level and so they said to be honors were
the ones that put him there then that
was it like that they were like the
beyonders put the put the energy there
and that's all we ever heard we have
never heard anything about the Beyonder
since like the one or two mentions over
the course of the entire Marvel
chronology and his appearance and his
appearance in Illuminati number like
which was a really great issue but also
explained that the Beyonder was not a
race of beyonders but in fact was a
inhuman mutant yes who I had a theory
about that by the way cuz like there's a
really cool moment I tossed it out on
the back when the been disbarred existed
before Brian Michael Bendis was like
torch say later community you can tweet
me if you want to talk to each other but
I was a member of the Menace board and I
was like and I read that issue and I was
like wow you're playing the long game
I thought that Bendis was capable of
doing what Jonathan Hickman is capable
of doing he's not but this is the thing
that he is capable I was like wow like
cuz [ __ ] cuz well in that there's a
moment in that issue where they go to
find the Beyonder and they like the
illuminati goes to some crazy planet
that's like that looks like Earth that
the beyond that is New York we're like
he's just been continuing the Marvel
Universe
but in his own sphere of influence and
they also say like they don't really
know how far his powers can reach
there's a moment we're like spider-man
and Luke Cage and so but and like
somebody else are doing some stuff and
blah blah and so that for me I was like
okay this foreshadows the formation of
the New Avengers and then there's a
moment where the Illuminati show up in
the talk of the Beyonder and then the
Hulk shows up and he smashes between
them and he says oh I'm sorry I forgot
to schedule that event yeah and I
thought that was their way of that was
venice's way of saying like you know how
World War Hulk kind of came out of left
field like as far as like these events
we're going like Avengers assembled
Civil War House of M World War Hulk and
then Secret Invasion and all the other
stuff I thought that like number one
Bennis with being meta and saying like
okay world war hulk kind of came out of
left field and we know that and we're
sorry but more importantly i thought it
was that they have beyonder had been
since secret wars to like creating
events but like he had been writing
Marvel yeah like that he'd been creating
events like and it the the effect of his
decisions had been like far-reaching I
think actually I think that Hulk
smashing the Illuminati in that episode
in that issue came before World War Hulk
came out and so when we're wall came out
I'm like wow that was random and
unexpected like when the Hulk had
appeared when he fought like when he was
when the viana was explaining things to
the Illuminati so I thought like crap
like what else happens while they're
talking and I started tracing like all
the things that take place in their
conversation and what's happening on
earth and then the Beyonder says like oh
where was I at the end of the issue
oh yes the world and he's in Times
Square and I'm like wow like so they're
gonna they're gonna explain that like
all these events are the beyonders fault
and that's how they're gonna undo Civil
War that's how they're gonna undo House
of em and that's how they're gonna undo
all these they and like change
everything nope nope that's not what
they're doing that wasn't so awesome
though because I think you come along
and they could just like it see I would
say they're probably credence to that
theory
they'd given it to Mendez if business
was the one riding yesterday Hickman the
minutes would come back and say hey guys
you ever like everything that's happened
after 19 like 85 and they're like yeah
yeah yeah that was real and we can reset
the whole thing in spiders and like we
can undo all that crap and make
everybody young again and Blair today
the Ben gist who writes x-men builds all
these really complicated problems then
fixes them in a couple panel slicker you
can kid like remember last Lausanne I
was raving cuz he brought Professor X
back yes professor X comes back fixes
all their problems then goes back in
time and wipes his own Michael what's
stopping I'm doing this every time well
the thing about Bendis is we were
talking about ben d'azyr li ER like I
think Rob Benny and I were talking about
that it's the other day or yesterday we
were talking about how like this have
been destroyed books he has a really
really great hook everyone says the last
sentence the other person says and then
there's a last page
bum bum bum omen and then the next issue
invalidates that page yes there was like
it's a great like harry potter tactic
just right the second and last sentence
but like at the last at the end of the
chapter but there were moments like in
ultimate spider-man which by the way
argue arguably the best thing Benison
has been I like his daredevil but yeah
ultimate spider also dig his daredevil
yes but his all but ultimate spider-man
number one to the most recent at the
issue of Ultimate Comics Spider Man more
what a Miles Morales or whatever the
hell they're calling that title now is
them in the best run of been missus ever
and there was an issue in that where
like friggin Spider Man is talking a
Nick Fury about like the venom goop and
he says like my dad was trying to cure
cancer and Nick and the last page reveal
is Nick Fury saying like your dad may
have just in like started World War 3
ooh
and then the next issue he's like really
and he's like no
don't that's not lighting
that's just trickery but it's funny I
don't know if you guys been keeping up
with a whole new x-men but it was funny
because Ben just wrote what I guess is
going to be one of the last adventures
of the ultimate x-men and of that
universe where they're just hanging out
that oh well bye guys
yeah it's done just by guys I'm like
well I thought this was going they fight
ultimate doctor do and I'm like well
this is going somewhere right he's gonna
say something yep nope just by or in
miles cases see you later I was really
expecting like you know it's funny how
hard some of these Marvel writers work
to make everything fit oh yeah and then
editor just editors just go no yeah like
I remember like remember when Spiderman
revealed his identity in Civil War and
everyone was like how are they gonna fix
this and then I want to say it was
either Christos Gage or the other guy
that I always confuse with Christos Gage
who but there's these two writers who
love Marvel continuity was the guy wrote
the New Warriors and it was probably
gauged I'm gonna say is what it is cuz
gage always writes stories like yeah and
he wrote I don't remember what the hell
it was that it was about it was the
initiative and he created the scarlet
spiders which was like - for context
people the Spider Man that awesome iron
spider suit created by Tony Stark after
spider-man like turncoat on Iron Man and
went and joined Captain America's team
doctor Iron Man was like I always
spider-man suits what am I gonna do with
him yes so he created like deputies of
iron spiders but since they were red
spider people he called them the scarlet
spiders either knowing that he's making
a joke about the clones or just being
cool and mentioning that but a team of
scarlet spiders and then later he
actually wound up using like they used
their cloaking technology to impersonate
Peter Parker and so there were three
Peter Parker's and in and created doubt
within the public consciousness of
whether Peter Parker was actually
spider-man or whether
was playing a game like for Tony Stark
creating doubt and like basically a like
creating a situation like daredevil with
Matt Murdock where he's like you know
I'm not really daredevil and like half
of America believes that he is and the
other half was like maybe he's not cuz
he's really pushing the issue that he's
not daredevil like a shirt that says I'm
totally not there yeah I love that I
also loved seeing Frank Castle in that
shirt but uh but that idea of like these
these writers working damn hard to
create to make to undo the decision but
within continuity so it kinda makes
sense and then editors is going like now
deal with the devil no magic no like I
thought that the all-new x-men like the
young of x-men they were eventually
gonna kill douche Cyclops you know
Archangel Jean like will Jean Grey is
dead and like everybody else and just go
this is it this is eerie x-men and
they're young now instead they just made
a much bigger mess yeah tour now it's
like the young Cyclops isn't even on the
team anymore with his dad he might know
buddy one who like makes it out of
Secret Wars with nothing with no
repercussions because he's too busy
being way over there with Corsair dude
dude it's an awful man like like it
amazes me how much they've they've
trashed the entire x-men franchise like
as soon as Fox was like we're never
giving you the right back says rights
back to x-men what was like you know
what was invited then we'll just like
trash the [ __ ] out of the franchise and
nobody's gonna give a damn and they did
that but and we don't they totally
trashed the cast we kept up with them
for like 30 40 plus issues and armies of
sight joy I can't freaking do this
anymore
I just it's just punishing every week
and I'm like no man this is gonna be
gone soon and secret I'm sure it'll be
good again it's like that I'll review it
when it's good again one amazing has
been alright Christopher Yost amazing
has been pretty good cuz it's just about
the teachers and like every arc is very
self-contained and it's very fun they're
doing a juggernaut one now cool
they found
the site erect crystal yeah and it's a
it's the living monolith it's not Cain
Marko anymore it's the living monolith
everyone remembers him right hold on the
living monolith has the gym of citta
right now yep he hasn't been relevant
since apocalypse was like I'm gonna
channel all your energy through him he
was called to the temple they did a
really cool story where guys like
crossbones and like all these other
really cool assassin characters we're
all called to the temple by like the
demon that lives in the crystal that's
like oh you want to be the new
juggernaut don't you and for some reason
the living monolith was the one that
picked it up and it's like nope it was
me I'm the chosen one
you know what I'm actually amazed that
Marvel didn't go like who will wield the
crystal who will become the juggernaut
like and have like a grid of characters
and then like create an event out of
that and make a bunch of tie-in issues
about like them maybe having like I'm
amazed they didn't do that it's actually
more of a colossus story which is the
funny thing cuz there's like a second
thing we took away this colossus gonna
get this now I hope not was done you can
already turn into friggin metal you
don't need him to turn into the
juggernaut with metal you look like an
idiot it was what's even funnier is that
storm and the other x-men don't even
really like or trust Colossus anymore
really like look they're like look
Phoenix floors friggin yeah ran off with
cable and stuff we don't like anymore
Peter yeah there enough you screwed up
we're not like yeah you're in the dog
house he's like oh no my muscles are sad
what would Wolverine do in this
situation
yeah probably team up with teenage girl
and go fight people and that's what he
does that's hilarious
he would probably join six teams and
then sell all of them yeah okay so you
guys know about like that how that whole
process starts like the whole locked
essence and everything with like the
Crimson gem of cyttorak and all the
other crystal know oh my god I know that
like you can absorb like it like calls
to you and you knew absorb it and then
you become a generator
no I think they host like there's a
contest this horse didn't Oh like all
right so way back in the day when they
were writing all this stuff
you had God you had the you had the etc
and then you had like 11 other deities
from like different dimensions like I
guess they originally inhabited earth
but the question they had is which of us
was the most powerful and so they said
like they're gonna make champions for
each of themselves basically and they're
gonna create artifacts and whoever is
capable of reaching and grabbing that
artifact will be their champion and
they'll be endowed with a portion of
their power and so that's like this
juggernaut came to be like he grabbed
the gym and became like the juggernaut
but nonetheless um yeah like that's
that's how that whole thing happens it's
like just one big competition kind of
thing they put on and it's like
constantly testing to see who the best
one is but um but anyway so so
spider-verse oh yeah so so then we were
talking about spider-verse yep we did
mention we talked about spider-verse so
get to it so you know I didn't like
spider-verse
I definitely know the ending didn't have
the oomph I thought it's funny how they
basically had the big action issue then
the epilogue I'm like well couldn't you
have put these two together actually
just feels like well okay I got my
action off and then I just got well
people talking yeah yeah it was it was a
little disappointing to me because I
thought the way like it was building up
it was gonna be like this huge massive
battle and let the massive battle is
like one page and then it's it's just
like okay you know what like we're just
gonna drop you into this irradiated
wasteland and then we're gonna lock you
in the box and then we're just gonna
leave and that's it yep yes you're too
good of villains and we can't totally
kill you off cuz we might want to use
you again later
powerful characters that you could
either resurrect or or bring in or just
or amplify the powers of a character
that's relevant to spider-man but don't
you vent interview with a vampire losers
like these inheritors I'm so sick of
these of every time more lunch shows up
I'm like well I could probably skip this
because he's so dumb he's so stupid but
he's got long black hair
French coat he wears suits and he's got
an ascot and he wants to make you with
like with with 90s Morbius power or
plasma oh my god yes Morbius from
excerpt was a spider-man I must feed on
plasma I remember more peas had a
short-lived series in Marvel no that
show was doing really well you don't oh
more bees had a shortage I remember when
they launched sensor is Mike Jones wrote
it lasted about six yeah and I reviewed
each of them and you know what they
weren't they were ninety spawn is what
it was Morbius goes to live in
Brownsville I just want to be left alone
so he makes friends with the hobos and
then he starts fighting like this is
spawn this is 90 spawn you're right
flagrant that did he make did he kill
people and then make a thrown out of
their bodies not that bad you kill
people and then he felt bad about it
that's what you know what that's
actually a little better than spawn
because I'm everyone's spawn came back
the second like when he died in issue 50
they were going to spawn now when spawn
power meter went down he went to hell he
fought his way all the way up to Mel
balsa and then made a second deal that
was nowhere near as powerful as the
first deal but it removed the power
meter and he made him like unchecked
powerfully and he like and then he
started killing people for Mel Bolger
and then made a thrown out of their
bodies and he went i never mind
i'm just gonna keep being spawn again
like he didn't feel bad at all he killed
his random people world I'm like who
who's in this throne like what are you
doing spawn book is the story they never
finish but it was he had to stop the
rose yes the rose rose Wilson fixes
Fisk's son the rep II don't know we
never saw under the mask I thought it
was Wilson fist son but we never saw
under the mat so he was fighting the
rose who is gonna use the ultimate
nullifier
what I yes yes the Rose gone guilt about
know he got the ultimate nullifier I
think he wanted to destroy Browns
as part of like some sort of real estate
scam oh my god and superior spider-man
showed up for like an issue because this
was when they were really pushing
superior to do like you know appearances
with everyone and that was the book it
lasted like six issues and I think I'm
the only one who remembers this book you
know that is absolute garbage like the
ultimate no the ultimate nullifier
destroyed Abraxas a multi-dimensional
being that just killed off an infinite
number of Galactus and they're just
gonna use it to like destroy the thing
that keeps Galactus I'm eating earth and
Morbius the living vampire a character
created in the same issue when
spider-man grew 6r has it that is so
dumb in the fact that that series just
like disappeared like not a single tear
was shed that day everyone's a series
mercifully it's like seeing a dead
animal just just just let it go they
built Morbius up like in the lead up to
superior like in the lead up to
spider-man like I forget if it was 600
or 700 oh yeah yet like a point one
issue where they retold his origin and
his life and everything yeah and I'm
like hey I still don't care about
Morbius the living vampire you know what
like any man yeah he is so crappy and
he's never been cool remember hey guys
look let's date ourselves you remember
the midnight sons Oh God
but yes like remember how cool he wasn't
that to remember the seven ghosts your
head hurts and Morbius and his split
personalities and his evil version where
it looks like spawn that was cool
there's a reason there's a reason why
nobody cares about that [ __ ] anymore by
the way where is our battle world
midnight son's book now so maybe you'll
get one hey guys give us a bad hello
world of midnight sons with evil Doctor
Strange and his crazy mask and like and
uh I think I don't remember what the
other ghostwriter there's Danny ketch
Ghost Rider
there's
Johnny Blaze going threader and then
there's Wild West one who dresses in
white well they even they have a book
which is called racers most races I like
that it's Philippe Smith liking writing
that one that dude needs a break he's a
good rider I'm it sucks that new Ghost
Rider had to get cancelled just when it
was getting really interesting how was
it
I did one actually what issued it
cancelled on cuz I had a prognostication
it got 12 issues along it I think it
literally got 12 I read issue 11 and
they actually open up the mystery and
tell you about the spirit that's in him
and they actually explain him like well
that's really good actually and they
were like you know what it is it's cuz
the spirit that's in him is not the
spirit of vengeance yeah it's this evil
hit man named Eli Mora who was a
sameness of course he's basically a Rob
Zombie character okay who killed people
and that's who he's able to possess
Robbie but in this last issue we found
out Eli Moro is actually Robbie's uncle
any MIT and he may have killed his
parents Oh
see how he's literally sharing his body
with the dude who killed his parent
that's cool see static shock said it
best that Akash said spider-verse sucks
because nothing happened like that's
pretty much it like nothing you were
about to quote the character static
shock yeah I thought he was gonna quote
the show like who I love the static
shock right or you're gonna quote the
Zeta project next dude Sal you are my
new best friend now because you remember
Zeta project how could I forget and the
two great Batman Beyond crossover yeah
oh god a project yeah another thing that
never got a conclusion nope anything you
like doesn't have an ending supposedly
one of the guys saw that MC 2 is getting
its own story in seeker wars 1 if that's
true or not well lately half of the
roster is on that Alex Ross poster
including American dream dark devil
Spider Girl I think is on that cover or
Spider Woman now
I mean spoilers just fighter verse but
you know alright let's stop let's let's
kill spider verse let's let's let's
let's release an inheritor on spider
errors and suck its venom draw am I am
it's over like I thought spider-verse is
gonna be this amazing huge story and it
was gonna be like okay this is gonna be
like the spider-man universes incursion
event wasn't it was just like it should
be like it should have been but it's
like here's like your Saturday night
spider-man story and I was like okay
yeah like this is like that was so weak
- it could have been like like four
issues like the whole thing including
all the tie ins and everything
oh yeah it's just been like four issues
you know cuz I mean like like Spider
Woman got her own solo story and okay
here's what happened it's about a
woman's solo story Peter Parker says go
to the more lune world she's like oh wow
everything's different here and
apparently I'm being more loon and she's
like the first for you she's add new
Spider Woman book had to be part of
spider-verse basically killed it dead
waste
yeah nobody cares oh and Reglan crew
what hate it's okay yeah I hated the
character so every time she turn around
she's like oh my god I screwed something
up and now I'm depressed and now I've
got to fix it and fixing it is only
gonna make it worse she's like a Steve
Urkel in the [ __ ] comic books like I
hated her character so much like oh my
god like like like Marvel's like you
have to identify with so we want you to
feel bad for so like I'm like you know
what I feel for smoke I feel [ __ ]
hatred is what I can
like I feel absolute disgust whenever I
look at the character is so I hate her
like I her character is just dumb like
sure he's me of like a fourteen-year-old
girl that's still trying to figure
herself out in the world
watching - is though is basically the
but I mean how can i really I'm thirty
thirty years old that's 131 and how can
I identify with a fourteen-year-old girl
that's the exact I have about the
current Batgirl book honestly where I'm
like there is I want to like this but
there's nothing at least with silk I'm
like you know I can kind of identify
with this sin at least they back loaded
this with a lot of interesting
spider-man characters like Jonah's a
regular in the black hat looks to be the
villain for it yeah so at least there's
that it's got more going for it can I
just say with respect to the Jay jonah
Jameson care
in the in the marvel 616 every new
status quo they've had for him in the
last 10 years or more has been great
like the idea of him okay so he's like
the publisher awesome classic we all
love Jay John James in the the irate
publisher with a with with with scruples
but kind of not and then they make him
into mayor and you think that's gonna be
kind of overplayed and it's not here
you're - yeah and then they make him
bill o'reilly that is brilliant
yep now of course it's brilliant in as
much as we've seen it in that horrible
ultimate spider-man cartoon but you know
what at least he's a character in the
comics in the cartoon show like he's
never off the TV like how sad sort of
issues a case Simmons for that at least
they got JK Simmons JK Simmons like
saved like JK Simmons saved J John
Jameson from just become a crappy
stereotypical character yeah well you
know did you know that Stan Lee was
hoping to play Jay Johnson back in the
day when they were like when like James
Cameron was yeah like thank God that
didn't happen that would be kind of fun
but it wouldn't like you know stands a
kami yeah molested he is really funny in
the new spider-man movie like those
emails where he's like maybe we could do
a story about spider-man being a good
guy
no yeah I love by the way really quick
just very quick like aside about J John
Jameson and and spider-man and spider
person Dan Slott I talked to Dan Slott
in 2008 at the Baltimore Comic Con and
actually it was back when I was trying
to get into making videos and stuff like
that and I filmed it on this really
crappy old DV camera so if you if you
hunt for it you could find my interview
with Dan Slott but uh and I got him by
the way to mention a whole bunch of [ __ ]
about that was during brand new day that
he was writing
and of course I you know I had it like I
was sitting on all these like great
reveals that like wouldn't be revealed
for another two years but I couldn't get
the damn thing out for like five so
doesn't matter but uh but he when he
writes the characters he imagines the
voices for them and does them and one of
the and one of the voices he does is j
jonah Jameson from this although all the
voices are pretty much from the 60s
cartoon show oh and his j jonah Jameson
impression leads me to believe that he
should have played janitor so he does
cuz he just launches into it he goes
like Parker and it's so perfect
well I'm like damn man you could do that
too yeah I miss too much Fan Expo the
year I went and I felt really bad about
that cuz I I had a bunch of questions
about anne-marie I wanted to ask man I
didn't even let me tell you something
man like if you ever do catch him he is
he's a fans creator like he loves his
fans he's really cool he's super
professional in every issue everything
you've ever written and I don't like
them I'm just going to sell them and so
he takes the stack and like and slot
signed all of them real but he didn't
sign all of them while I waited to meet
him to have him signed one issue he went
I'm gonna Simon he said to give any
question you want chatting guys like
know what a room your foot so slots like
okay I want you to go over here and give
me your stack and every once in a while
I will like break it up so like he
literally just books came in sign sign
sign while he's talking to real people
who want to engage him in conversation
like I'm like hey man like I really
loved your big time and blah blah blah
and he's like thanks man so much and
like he's like you know it's a
little-known fact he always gives some
kind of like back like behind the scenes
tidbit about something that he did or
something that's coming up
don't tell anybody this but new huh like
but I'm bringing that Gargan back as a
scorpion you know that kind of thing uh
and then but then like we'll go back
like between each real person who wants
to talk to him
he'll just sign in those crazy books
until they're all gone I'm like you
don't know how to do it like and I
admire that tenacity man like he can
yeah he's just being a vet in the
industry just being like the millionth
comic-con I'm sure he's been to oh yeah
that's crazy like I mean I couldn't
imagine like like a writer or an artist
for anybody in the industry saying like
I will sign every last one of these like
just give me some time you know again
like that's that's unbelievable there's
only one other creator I've ever seen do
that and it was Brian Michael Bendis
yeah
which believe it or not was because I'm
like and Bendis you know he had like at
one point had like eight titles like
month eight monthly titles going on at
the same time like and so the guys I can
I have them all from like 2000 to 2005
like here you go and he signed them all
I'm like that's awesome Oh like it was
really cool but catch him cuz it's
totally worth it and I really want to
you got you know you got a do man you
gotta come to New York Comic Con cuz he
lives in the city so he's always there
well he's trying to get me there we're
talking about Montreal actually just new
people little they were talking about
much y'all cause it's not far from
Vermont for him that's not far for me I
don't know if I could do Montreal man
that place is like a frozen land yeah
yeah it is I'm in Jersey and it's all
and I can't know though it's snowing
right now yeah garbage nucular winter
yes it's like 53 right now and it's
supposed to drop like 30 degrees
overnight that's [ __ ] crazy but no um
see this this is what's really like
interesting to me about about what
they're gonna be doing with all this
like my question isn't necessarily about
like the stories that are coming and
secret Wars and like convergence because
we know like with secret wars apparent
they're gonna be either like continuing
the alternate realities that like and
see here's a kicker I don't care what
happened after old man Logan right
everything that mattered happened in the
story we saw yes sorry so why do I care
what him and some little kid do like in
the future of that stuff I mean the
whole baby yeah yeah like the entire us
hope baby like
I don't know you know what I like I want
to see that like I want to see that
bleed over like maybe make a great
meatloaf of Marvel Universe out of
everything like if they were like yeah
the the x-men are all like we're gonna
reboot the whole x-men thing and just
bring back x-men 92 like yes like just
take those things and then make one
universe out of it like hey listen the
x-men are cool again they're like they
look like they're drawn by Jim Lee like
it's great and and well but Wolverine
still dead and we're gonna bring back
old man Logan and he's gonna be the
Wolverine of this universe okay like but
like do something like what cuz wouldn't
it be cool to have like a grizzled old
Wolverine who's older like I don't know
I mean like it less gristle that he is
already but older right like the entire
time see I was thinking about how like I
was getting to the story and I was I was
thinking cuz it was like a whole big
Rouge about Mysterio but I'm sitting
here like reading this and I'm trying to
see it from the perspective was like one
of the kids who's leaving
so he's like literally slashing through
the x-men he's like we're the expert at
it's funny too because you know we're
divvying up all the different titles for
review and just when we think we're done
they keep announcing new ones like over
the last like hey there's a new runaways
now and there's a new another x-men
story from another era and agenda is
getting reboot oh okay I'm only if J Lee
is drawing the damn thing things but I
have to think about like putting those
up on like a channel it's like look does
anyone under the age well say what under
my age actually care about this story
that's really you know what that might
have my almost before the video like
what era do you care about like I'm
gonna mention a bunch of books and I
need you to just gonna like rate them
based on give a [ __ ] versus whatever
whatever yeah I like like they're doing
like was it fists have come for kung fu
that's awesome that I'm like no one
cares about this wait a minute
here's a problem they're gonna do with
with Iron Fist kung-fu world alright
it's gonna be [ __ ] stupid you're
basically gonna head it's gonna be like
House of M except instead of mutants the
skinny people who study martial arts
yeah that's gonna be that reality and
let me tell you something I don't give a
[ __ ] about that
I mean I don't want to read a story
where they're like if you don't study
martial arts like you are less than it's
like watching a Kurosawa film no no I
just wanted to toss this out there it
looks like we have breaking news in the
chat that the signed spider-man MCU
although officially the signed of
spider-man of the MCU it looks like now
and the check he's trolling me but it
looks like Dylan is it it looks like
it's Dylan Ryan Dylan O'Brien okay so
it's the one that everyone's been saying
it's the one that everyone it's the one
that lets you know review spoiled
yesterday there you go that's the thing
about working online I'm rarely
surprised about things anymore I'm like
like we've heard rumblings of this for
we and again latina review hasn't been
wrong though has yeah but I don't know
that kids so I have never seen him in
anything oh he wasn't he was on The Maze
Runner that was a good movie actually
what I didn't see me so they've nailed
him down for two major franchises so
he's gonna be The Maze Runner and the
Spider Man ashamed okay making more Maze
Runner movies or is that kind of a fire
Maze Runner is a three part series I
read the books only three yeah you can
do that um and he's apparently he was in
Teen Wolf oh oh the show yeah that
disastrous show not the movie I would
like to say yeah what the hell that's
the movie was great there's yeah there's
only one Teen Wolf out there and that's
Michael J Fox well there's an Bateman
Teen Wolf but uh no Teen Wolf - there's
only one - that's great hey you know
what since we're never gonna say Teen
Wolf again for another couple of years
you should check out the end credits of
Teen Wolf there's somebody with their
pants - right when Michael J Fox shoots
the winning bass
Paul and his mooning the mooning I think
it's a woman her pants are like unzipped
and like open it's not there's not
there's no flashing I think like in
Family Guy they say that use like
there's someone's penis is out it's not
it's just it's just this woman didn't
button her pants and you just see from
the waist down so you never see her face
and I've been trying every once in a
while team will be on I'm like who's in
the crowd where are you
where's your shame and but like she's
cheering and then she notices that her
pants are open and then she desperately
tries too tight to close them doesn't
and then the credits are finally like
but it says constant desperate like
embarrassing struggle and you're like it
won't go away it's the saddest I feel so
bad
but it's also so hilarious like this is
a pruder taped you're just sitting there
playing a bit back into the left back
here's the moment where she notices that
her pants are on that are open and she's
dead center over Michael J Fox his head
so there's no way that it's not being
seen right now okay so so remind me
because I always apparently I'm getting
this too confused
um he is for extinction is the one where
Cassandra Nova kills everybody in
Genosha I think so what was extinction
agenda extinction agenda was was more of
a like a no I thought that was an
apocalypse event that was looked at up
it was a havoc was in it it was a group
of Geno Sheehan magistrates backed by
the cyborg Cameron Hodge including an
amnesiac on Ice Road attack the
x-mansion and kidnap storm and the New
Mutants yeah
it's about Cameron Hodge it's not yeah
okay I don't give a [ __ ]
Cameron okay Cameron Hodge was cruel for
like four that is three issues of X
Factor he's like hey guys like I'm the
one who's bankrolling the new X Factor
so like alright cool like we're not
gonna have to go broke doing this yeah
and he's like you know what like I was
only doing this to steal your technology
Warren Worthington and now I'm gonna
turn against you and then it was just
yeah
characters they've already lost track up
after axe yeah oh my cute a bad are we
gonna see where this goes
no we lost track of them know what's
even funnier is the cover of the new
uncanny x-men has Cyclops fighting havoc
on the cover and the solicitation says
oh in the fallout of axis array it has
enough he doesn't show up in it it's a
lie behind he lied right to your face
I'd rather see like a story about Vulcan
then I would rather see a story about
either one of the Vulcan it was supposed
to be gambit gambit was the lost sight
Klaus brother not Vulcan somebody said
who's Rayna on agents of shield okay
guys look people are gonna ask me that
question for a while now alright Raina
and agents of shield is not like Raina
in any capacity in Marvel Comics a
Marvel comic she's a member of like an
alien race that has like their own cast
of mutants and like she's a member of
their equivalent of like the x-men or
some something like that has nothing to
with the Inhumans I am here's what
here's my here's my bet and somebody in
the comments actually I think it posted
this too I think she's gonna be Tigre
the equivalent of Tigre and in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe that it really
matter though the only important secret
ever had where she was recording the
meeting of Secret Avengers and then like
she was a spy for Ironman that's like
the only importance she's ever had see I
think that like Marvel see this is what
I really think
I think Marvel just doesn't know what
their fan base wants like I think Marvel
was like okay guys look like we have an
opportunity here with like the entire
multiverse to like fix it basically or
so like consolidated down so here's what
we're gonna do future imperfect yeah
years of Future past which is probably
gonna be like a continuation of that
story or like oh that is a great idea a
switch past is great and see like no I
think that's a great idea
I don't I don't think it's a good idea
here's why everything that had to do
with Days of Future past was answered in
Days of Future past and days of future
present we don't know you know anything
more than that like that people like
that and they remember it makes them
feel comfortable - oh my my money is
that Reyna is minxie makes it was a
handmaiden of what's-her-name of the
Medusa she looks like what they showed
rayna's eyes to be so really that's my
I'm calling it now minxie also she
doesn't matter and who cares so I can
put her in the Asians of shield show and
won't affect anything how cool was it
agent Carter we got dr. Faustus how cool
was that
that was super okay I will swear to this
attuned from now and so Marvel debunk
said that was a ring of the Mandarin and
I posted that stuff I put it on reddit
or on reddit Marvel then I posted on
okay we've been getting a lot of that
recently and we wondered who started
that I posted it on reddit Marvel
Studios and people were like boo like
your opinions are different than mine
and I was like okay and they're like we
[ __ ] love this theory and I'm like oh
it makes sense like the rings on the
same hand that the Mandarin keeps his on
like the ring gives and he does the
exact same thing and people are like
well it's the way that he modulates his
voice and stuff like that okay I could
kind of see that happening but I the
only reason why it would matter that it
was dr. Foster's is if they plan on
killing off Captain America because
that's the only significance he had like
he hypnotized Sharon Carter into killing
caps that are shooting Captain America
and yelling him and so I you know I
guess maybe they might do that but for
more movies than chrysanthus Oh what
should that tell you yeah also they seal
them off that means moviegoers get to
feel what we comic book fans feel it's
the return of the guy you like yeah by
the way I guarantee if they kill him at
the end of Civil War
infinity war 1 or 2 they're gonna crack
out a cosmic cube
Captain America will jump right the hell
out of it or they'll use an infinity gym
they'll use like the the soldier he'll
come out of the soul gym or something
like they'll use some cool thing from
the Marvel Pantheon they created of the
the mystical devices and bring them back
to life because we know that we know
that Thor is gonna well you know we know
Thor might be having some I think total
way it might be doing something might be
going away because we saw that pool in
the thing in the trailer the pool that
Rob says is the well of death or
whatever oh I think I think it's the
Infinity well but it might it is no
question I mean it's in the realm of mr.
Smith so yeah yeah no that isn't that it
was just like a pool in like a pool of
water inside Wakanda somewhere I don't
know the money what's where they're
keeping all the money from all the money
in a pool actually saw the hilarious
thing somebody was talking about JJ
Abrams if they posted on reddit they
said JJ Abrams was directing Star Wars
Episode 7 when they when they first when
DC announced they were gonna arrive
Disney announced they were gonna do that
and somebody posted a comments saying
that JJ Abrams will not be available for
questioning but he will be available to
be seen like humping a giant pile of
money
he's probably got to be making an
obscene between Star Trek and Star Wars
or like stars fans are getting all
pissed off and start you know you can't
do both it's like sure with that much
ILM did the Star Trek movies yeah like
it's already got a comment I read a
great comic with role equates Star Trek
and Star Wars is gonna be done by the
same and is that even legal no no it's
not he's breaking the law yeah you
should probably go arrest him
but um yeah no so okay so here's the
other thing so with with convergence
like here's my question how many of the
how many alternate realities do you
think are really or how many like in old
stores you think are really gonna be in
there because what do you see is said is
this is our chance to like touch base
with the old fans like the pre-crisis
I'm sorry the the post-crisis but the
pre flashpoint fans yeah like we're
gonna touch base with you guys like I'm
wonder how much of that old continuity
is gonna be there but I mean see here
here's the thing like you see came out
and they said look guys like we've
invested way too much money in new 52
that continuity is not going anywhere
yeah post convergence like it's staying
like it's gonna be here forever you know
until we change it again in like five
years but nonetheless yeah the fact
remains is they're not gonna get rid of
that continuity so I'm what I'm thinking
is they're gonna bring in like some of
the some of the old like the pre pre pre
flashpoint stories and then like kill
them off over the course of like two or
three issues you know old school
Superman he's married to Lois isn't that
nice take that away for a moment I mean
partly quitted her old costume isn't
that great as she's gone now yeah let's
get rid of her and put her in a really
really skanky I mean here's Roy Harper
but he's still Arsenal and his daughter
still you learn nothing oh my god you
had a chance to fix it you didn't and
Ted Kord is still dead
well see people are saying stuff like
well maybe they'll bring back maybe
they'll like they'll bring in Superman
red Sun but here's a problem with
bringing in Superman red Sun like the
ending of the comic was a billion years
in the future so like if you change any
of it it undoes itself it does it
completely changes everything because
how can you inject any kind of change in
that when it follows such a really
tight-knit quantum chronology of things
yeah like like Mark Miller doesn't
really leave a gap in terms of like what
happens between any period of time like
I mean you get the time when Superman
first shows up and the Americans are
like holy [ __ ] they've got Superman or
yeah you know some super powerful guy
and then it follows almost perfect
chronology until it becomes a repeating
cycle where Superman gets or I guess in
the future a billion years in the future
where they send you know Superman to the
Past or whatever does something like
that I can't remember but yeah
nonetheless you know any other big
things to for convergence is of course
is that this I'm sure will be the moment
where they fuse the universes of Earth
one and earth two so all the earth to
people they've been prepping in their
own universe and there
own book are gonna fill the roles that
are not already filled so hey you get a
doctor fate now guys cuz he was over
there now he's over here like the funny
thing is when they're talking about like
oh maybe they might merge earth too and
her I'm like didn't they do that yet
haven't they done that yet like isn't
that done like come on with that idea
like since Trinity war they're like hey
the universe is kind of know each other
exist right like just just end it like
put them on the thing and make it one
story like and by the way we're talking
about like what like they've they've
invented too much time in the new 52
continuity what continuity like what
plan what roadmap have they followed the
one that the one that like whatever like
they don't have any plan like they're
there they're doing damage control for a
very hasty decision they made three
years ago with respect to like the old
things I think that like they'll just
pick and choose things they like and
kill everything else I mean like yeah
we'll probably stay the same with the
writers there have or at least Batman
will stay this yeah yeah Batman will
remain wherever they want it to be and
Grant Morrison will write whatever it is
he wants to write and everyone else will
have to just get with the program as
they have been for the last few years
well yeah well that was kind of the fun
thing is DC came out and they said like
okay like post convergence we're gonna
be giving like a lot of these characters
of stories like new writing teams like
Scott Slater's name means it not
challenged like it was it was so like
Scott Snyder post convergence and why
would they give it to anybody else so
that was a really good point but yeah
like where they're doing like new
writers a new artist for all these
different characters I think like Harley
Quinn's getting a new a new writer and a
new artist and and around but him and
his wife are also doing a miniseries
Harley Quinn is powerful and he's
getting Starfire - yes yeah that's right
okay cuz they want him to work the same
magic you worked on Harley Quinn for
Starfire - which I'm like yes please
make it so I don't hate this character
anymore
please we gotta get you and and Faust
you know in a chat together because he
is oh I know I've watched the show that
he was on where he was going off but I'm
like oh it's a good thing I'm not in
this room yeah it would have to be so
amazing
Mia we have our own convergence yeah
like I it's very hard for me to get
excited about convergence because
nothing that's happening in 52 excites
me except for what Snyder and Kapila are
doing a Batman kind of and so man like
after after convergence what I would
like to see is more Elseworlds books
like I would like them to do more really
cool self-contained stories yeah I would
like to see more kingdom come I don't
want to see them make Kingdom Come Canon
I just want to see more their new 52
version it came out like I would like to
see them do cool things with with with
their carry-ons
it needs that look to be outside the
thing like a bizarro thing by Heath
corner but that can't be in the main II
know anyway pres I'm like that also
can't be in the main unit right baby I
mean like the thing about it is like I
remember when they were doing when they
did birth right and like it was just
gonna be a self-contained they were
gonna I don't know I don't think they
even had Elseworlds anymore I think they
like a ban in that title at that point
but they were gonna do like a kind of
Delos worlds kind of story with it like
here's a updated version of Superman's
origin enjoy and everyone liked it so
much the DC is like and it's a Canon -
yep yeah because you liked it because
that made money you got something to
that yet earth one wants a woman at some
point - maybe at one point we'll get
earth one Wonder Woman one of these days
I don't think so three and worth one one
when I'll come out like give me a give
me a book that's called like Superman's
origins and tell me that like it won't
sell it's true they're all great I have
like two or three of them and they're
great like this that's what they
basically come to like you had you had
post-crisis and he had like Superman Man
of Steel and they're like okay guys like
the next two or three comic books for
Superman's origins are like for reals
though like you know his origins this
time like for really reals it's like
okay look you know what yeah
we promise yeah like we won't change it
in two years yeah I mean that this was
gonna happen like post conversions I
guarantee they're gonna come back and
they're gonna say okay like for reals
guys like this time for reals like this
is Superman's origin like Burgess you
know I'm not looking forward to like
Aquaman has been in the middle of one of
his well maybe his greatest run ever
from Jeff Jones to the new guy I'm
really not gonna looking forward to it
when post convergence it's like hey
Aquaman's Jason Momoa now guys isn't it
funny how that happens yeah yeah hey
look taco man has black hair and he
looks like Conan and enjoy that nonsense
it's well let's just disrupt what you
were doing with that because because
this movie is gonna make Bank hopefully
and if it doesn't then I guess we'll
just be stuck with it cuz like look if
you don't care if you're happy having a
great run we did it to gray arrow we'll
do it to you too
arrow is such a crappy book right now Oh
Jeff Lemire was getting so good like
Jeff Lemire reinvented the wheel and he
was going in this really gray where he
like whole new origin and everything and
then they're just like ah I'll Emir
buddy we got the show riders we kind of
want to do this the show is you know can
really I don't know how much I don't
even know how much money this show is
bringing in but it's way more than what
you're bringing in and they're changing
it again after convergence they're
getting a new writing team to our team
because we need like sister baby organs
this one guy what I love about Green
Arrow's he keeps changing cuz at the
beginning of the new 52 he was
Smallville Green Arrow then they changed
him again to where he was like I like
the old comic version then he became the
new ninja Jeff Lemire version now he's
just TV arrow and they're probably gonna
change him again to something else for
the fifth time
oh yeah oh no they'll do it they'll
change it but in earth to Matt's tell me
and earth you they just introduced the
Oliver Queen of Earth to do and he's
classic Green Arrow stupid TV green
arrow I mean would that be funny where
it's like hey mate earth green arrow
you're dead or a few guys replacing me
super bad it was more if he's more
popular what the hell yeah they'll do
that like if the earth - green arrow
turns out to be able because I assume
has his own solo series from earth-2 um
no he does he just introduced him now in
us oh oh he's just now okay here's the
funny thing
red arrow caught her Hawke predates
Oliver Queen and earth - oh really yeah
we're gonna feel weird so yeah so is his
life - like Green Arrow like Oliver
Queen is just now becoming green arrow
or he's being introduced as you know
it's been really okay okay he's actually
very wearing the red arrow costume and
people are asking like well why wait so
was he a guy before is re just becoming
a guy now okay and the problem with
futures end in worlds and is that
futures and takes place after worlds end
so futures end
spoils huge chunks of worlds and you
already know who lives on worlds end
because they showed up in futures that
ya see there's a bunch of cool
characters are like just you just know
ain't gonna make okay see that
continuity stuff doesn't make any sense
to me like like you see here's here's
one of the big things like like people
were asking me like they've been asking
like you know periodically you know a
handful of people here and there you
know if Franklin Richards are so
powerful why did he stop the incursions
and I'm like okay guys like this is
gonna be an answer you're not gonna like
because it's gonna be filled with a
bunch of convoluted nonsense you know
and and like back through like I would
like through and looked at it like
here's here's the problem alright as a
New Avengers number 29 Franklin Richards
is dead like they killed him off Reed
Richards is like we're gonna hook you up
to a machine and we're gonna use your
reality warping powers try to end the
incursions BAM you're dead and I was
like okay well I guess that's it like no
more Franklin Richards
yes yet somehow given the power of comic
books this you know Franklin Richards
was alive five thousand years in the
future the other he could talk to
Captain America and so the paradox is
how the hell does that happen and why
the same guy the same guy he knows he'll
do LOL he'll fix it I guess he will man
because it because up to this point like
people are like how is like people like
you know how does this work late I was
going through Reddit and I was looking
at forms people I understand how this
works Marvel was just kind of like well
you know
yeah that's like they're like well
because they don't freaking know because
because Hickman has been really playing
it close to the chest it's the first
time and it's so funny how like getting
what we're talking about in curses again
but like the fact that like he is gonna
have to like he needed to give like an
info dump in that last issue with hank
pym where he's just like so okay guys
here's all these formation cuz we killed
Living Tribunal like two years ago and
then never told you anything about it so
here's all the info like I feel like
it's funny that he's been hinting at
things but at the same time like not
giving us literally any information
until finally like until now yeah well
we have a we have a saying over on my
channel whenever something doesn't make
sense we're like and why did that happen
because comic books comic books comic
books that's why like when superior
spider-man crosses his own timeline
the master weavers like oh and you won't
remember any of this cuz because you
crossed your own timeline oh my oh so
comic books comic let's go it looks
that's what it's like it's almost like
slot didn't even write the damn thing
because how do you write like he
literally had the reason why it works in
the book like in spider-verse like Doc
Ock doesn't remember any of the or
doesn't affect any of this superior
spider-man because he thinks that Peter
Parker's from the past yeah yeah what is
that the future ruins that so now we
have to make it so the time travel makes
you forget your suit makes you forget
things that's that you know why they had
to have that - because fans really
wanted amazing to fight superior he
already did and they fought and the
thing is is that piers only like half
fighting cuz he's like it's okay Sookie
I know you're gonna do the right thing
of edge I'm not mad you for trying to
destroy reality it's yeah Peter this is
not the guy who ran with a guy who led
led to the team and spider-verse was not
my people yeah yeah in reality fingers
he
anything he just got like idiot versions
of himself killed and then fought one
vampire and then put them in a like
retcon bunker that we'll eventually
discover the right
the last major revealed Uncle Ben where
was like well it's not uncle like we
it's a freaking totem like we know it's
not Uncle Ben like what like is this
surprising anyone like yeah is anyone
like whoa what's gonna happen what's
gonna happen is he's gonna probably
either die in the fight or leave and one
of the two things happens and surprising
no one like nothing in that book was a
surprise interesting or relevant to the
characters that it was about like well
see here was the other problem too like
and this is what I didn't like about
about this or like one of the big things
I didn't like like Dan Slott comes along
and he says okay guys look like there's
a reason why like all of this is
happening there's this big prophecy and
stuff like that and I'm the master
weaver and I spin the web of life yeah
the prophecy reality yeah and I'm like
okay look like let me see let me
understand this like we've got a
multiverse with like the Living Tribunal
that oversees it and like the ham and
all this kind of stuff but there's like
also like the multiverse a spider first
customer spider believers and I'm like
okay so how does Peter Parker fit into
this like well you know and I was like
okay God you know what like this is this
is stuff I'm hoping they correction like
I'm hoping that post Secret Wars Marvel
like we what we need is another like
joke asana
alright to like to come along and just
be like okay guys look like at least I
think it was Joe Quesada he was the
editor in chief for a while right they
had like that iron standard day and he
was like everything has to make sense
and if it doesn't make sense the [ __ ]
doesn't go out said he's the guy who
told JMS when they wrote one more day
when they really quick aside when they
did one more day and like spider-man's
to deal with Mephisto it wasn't Mephisto
the plan or all right maybe it was
Mephisto but it was Joe casados idea to
use Mephisto but Straczynski was like
okay we're gonna use time travel and he
changes one
and he spent weeks rewriting
spider-man's timeline so that all the
books still happen but the marriage was
undone by this one change and like and
like he Quesada is like oh and bring
back Harry Osborn's was like okay I can
make all those stories still happen and
bring back Harry Osborn and undo the
marriage but keep everything still
happening by changing all this stuff and
like he effected this whole I wrote this
whole like timeline and then cuz I was
like no that's too complicated just make
it a magic and casada and and
Straczynski he's like no you can't just
make it magic because it has to be
explained it has to make sense and
casada is quote and he said it and
because since keep went to the internet
the day that book came out and
quarterman said it's magic Joe we don't
have to explain it so the guy who says
that magic is magic is a is a retcon
button and doesn't need to be explained
no there's no way okay then who was it
who was the chief that came out and so
they're like all like like anyone any
kind of like time travel or anything
like that like it has to be done in a
way where it makes sense it could have
easily been Quezada it could have but
yeah like it's the Darth Vader think he
started out as the great hope but then
he turned to the dark side yeah hey man
like it was a dark time in the indica in
the galaxy when casada and Bill Jamis
came along and like fixed no wait yeah
yeah no I I thought that was I don't
know maybe I maybe I'm wrong but no I
remember there was a time right okay but
that's what we need is like somebody
like PostSecret worse to come back and
just be like okay guys look like if
you're gonna use any kind of time travel
here like it has to make sense like like
to me time travel should be like a last
resort in any story because it has
become stupid and that's that's the but
that was a problem with used it whenever
he wants to for x-men just time travel
all day every day till nothing matters
it it was like I thought that there was
gonna be like a really epic reason why
there was so much time travel being used
in the last few years I don't write it
seemed like there was gonna be like all
of Marvel now was time travel time
travel time travel like what the crap a
lot of time travel and uh
it like it no like if you if you make it
make sense it works but they don't care
and they didn't plan it so sorry like I
think I think maybe in one issue of mark
Wade's halt back when he was
time-traveling like one of the
time-traveling villains was like in case
you heroes did notice you've been doing
a freaking number to the space-time
continuum lately you've turned into
goddamn Swiss cheese yeah thanks for
that guys that's clean like bidness even
talked about that while being age of
Ultron like twenty stock was like you
can't just start jumping back and forth
on time all the time cuz you're gonna
break it Wolverines like man [ __ ] that
noise like yeah there is what I do and
what I do is ruin the space-time
continues that's the problem is is like
it all just becomes like this big huge
convoluted and nonsense which is why
like I've long since said Marvel's do
for like a continuity reboot not a
continuity you know reconciliation
alright they don't need to like it get
rid of so some alternate universes they
need it should just be like alright guys
like the continuity stops here but this
is everything after this is zero year or
this is your everything after this is
the spark you know like I would be ok
with that as long as wha - which they
freaking killed if wha - was our like
narrator of the Marvel Universe and was
like and one door closes and another one
opens and we keep our - let me keep 616
- ah - and everything else reboots yeah
I don't really want the the ball and
chain Nick Fury I like oh but don't
forget there's also another watcher that
like likes to watch people have creepy
fights in their houses in the form of
the sea that was that was the problem
with who watch who like for the longest
time people were like there's only one
no a watch it was like a multiversal
construct yeah like he existed in the
multiverse and he saw oh he's all the
what if books yeah he does and that was
like okay like and I say here's here's
my question like there's always thing
about this the other day like I was
now I was got missin some Issa guy juice
and I was thinking like what are they
gonna do with Nick Fury order model just
like forget about him
they forgot he's gonna become ultimate
Nick Fury after Secret Wars cuz ultimate
Nick Fury is in the movies done that in
the beginning they should have just done
that when they decided that they found
Sam Jackson dick fury more interesting
than old-school like cold war-era Tom
Selleck yeah they shoulda just because
like they did it in Supreme like in the
Ultimate Universe when Nick Fury goes
over to supreme power and he gets stuck
there and he has to like live in that
universe they've established a precedent
of Nick Fury being like I've been in
alternate realities before and I've been
in charge they could have just had an
issue where Nick Fury is like you know
putting on his shoes and then like Frank
Castle goes done and just puts one in
his in the back of his head and Nick
Fury gets this plate like ultimate Nick
Fury like what's more complicated saying
that like the black Sam Jackson ik
theory in the 6:16 is the illegitimate
son of real Nick Fury and he rose
through the ranks of shield and lost an
eye and or it's just Nick Fury from
another universe he just showed up and
that he's so much easier and just and
can you imagine I would love to see
ultimate Nick Fury in the 616 universe
because ultimately again a doesn't take
any [ __ ] and B is like would be so
baffled by everything be like so a
Galactus huh that's pretty freakin weird
like he but he'd also be like I've seen
it all so alright I'm in like my
security clearance seems to work so I
guess I'm Nick Fury now like I'll take
it
well he's gonna still work yeah yeah
we're really quick gar five five rocks
one yes we've seen Power Rangers
whatever moving on yeah whatever
it's the guy wanted to make a sci-fi
short that was really cool and then adi
shankara's like make it about Power
Rangers and a million people will watch
it and he's like I don't like Power
Rangers and shankar's like I don't care
and the guys like cool and he did and
that's the movie here's my thing like if
it was supposed to be like this
genius parody about well when you take a
kid's franchise and you greedy it up and
yes Michael Bay it up and like he's
trying to make a point about it but the
more I hear about it the more I watch
like oh that you you weren't doing a
parody were you you you were being so
that was really cool taking you
seriously it's cool and fun like it's
cool and like ridiculous there but like
you know whatever the only people who
did like we're hi I'm Saban who's like
no no we're doing a reboot like we can't
let this be better than what we're doing
yeah I love that that they just stopped
on that sevens like hey give us Megazord
Power by the way they reversed it and
now the ulti unrated versions on Vimeo
and the rated versions on YouTube and
yeah and I think this I'm sure they get
it and they get a cut man you know what
man let me tell you something all right
the Power Rangers I remember back from
the 1990s you had Kimberly and she is
like oh hey Jason you're kind of cool
and then Tommy came along and she was
like man [ __ ] you Jason Rangers caught
Doody she actually ended up with skull
ain't that some weirdness with what what
yeah they imply that in later seasons
that's how it worked out oh hey no
hooking Balkan schools like a teacher in
real life he's like a drama teacher in
real life he's like a professor
those dudes did really good for
themselves for them they almost had a
spinoff the room was almost a Vulcans
golf spin-off back in the day they were
gonna run a hotel but but the network
was like wow this is dumb even for us
yeah that's so dumb yeah that's that
never would have succeeded that would
have been an absolute travesty like I
remember like they used to have those
little messages at the end like like it
was funny towards one we're like when
they first yeah
the laser guns whatever it was and and
they were like hey guys like even though
we're Power Rangers and we use guns like
you shouldn't use guns like if you see a
gun like you should tell your parent and
like
dispose there is safety like wait a
minute you have a child if they found a
gun they should put it somewhere and
then go tell it
like you're gonna try a kid to handle a
[ __ ] hand don't play with toy guns in
a few I actually watched the first
episode of Dino charge which is like the
twenty second twenty four season yeah it
took them this long they've actually
hired actors for the show now oh no
that'll change no thing I know the
quality is alone oh my god these guys
are remoting and actually getting stuff
across to me like dispensing with the
origin to like eight you're all Rangers
now it's powered you know the deal get
out there and fight some monsters thank
you that was like the most crushing
thing as a kid because like as a kid I
guess as an adult now but as a kid I was
like oh my god the powers are so good
like the acting is so solid and it's
just like it's the greatest show
everything like I go back and watch it
now and it's like this is painful to
watch do what they remastered the first
season of power H and they put like
really terrible Adam West like Kapow
kaboom what's and like 10th oh God this
was real this was real remastered
powering that they tried to re air on TV
between like the Disney and Saban era ya
know so they took a cheesy show and they
made it even cheesier that's work that's
terrible no yeah anyway guys so yeah so
we're coming up on on the end of the
show you guys have any people know what
you're doing oh yeah let's do it man you
know all sorts of different stuff
happening you know new reviews every
week as always blog I guess tomorrow's
Wednesday so we're gonna have to get
back and do it all over again I excited
for new Hawkeye that's coming out
excited for a a bunch of the books that
we're gonna see uh we're talking about
bringing comic book clash in the
foreseeable future we hope to that's our
vs. show that we do oh god what else are
we working on Oh crisis Week is coming
up as well crisis week we keep talking
about it rights this week where we talk
about all the superhero movies that were
gonna happen but never did have
the Batman vs Superman that you were
gonna get before but never happened we
talked about was it like God we talked
about so many oh we talked about amazing
spider-man 3 because that officially is
not happening do you guys talk about the
Batman the Joel Schumacher Batman 5 or
not about that that was gonna be like
with with potentially Jeff Goldblum as
the Scarecrow oh my god his apology
movie right the Joker's dog that
would've been really weird [ __ ] is
exactly what I would have it would have
been there would have been some [ __ ]
sorry Joel you spent two hundred million
dollars on a pile of crap you don't get
to make an apology apology movies Batman
Begins that apparently Joel Schumacher
in real life is just very apologetic
he's like look they told me to make it
to a commercial I mean it's funny cuz
like Joel Schumacher actually is not a
bad director he made phone booth and
stuff like he's falling down you wanna
run from Joel Schumacher you got a watch
falling down where it's just like yeah I
can see what they thought this dude
could do Batman so good that's our
homework for this week kids go watch
falling down falling down viewers yeah
go see Hank Hank Pat Janet Van Dyne the
the whole town like one of my favorite
scenes is when those guys try to shoot
him they do the drive-by shooting and
they miss and like he walks up and he
shoots them in the leg he's like you
missed me later with Hank Pym we're
still talking about that one time he hit
his wife even though like Reed Richards
was way more like emotionally and
psychologically oh yeah - sue oh so much
of the point that Venture Brothers it's
a whole joke on bench brothers would
like be Impossibles that they have
yeah but it's still like but not but the
Hank fainted hit his wife though
probably why he can't be in the star of
the main move because once the media
which gets everything wrong would get a
head that's like is Marvel making a
wife-beater the star of their new movie
like wife beater becomes superhero yeah
like they'd be like oh my god one was
advocating like beating your wife
yeah like hey kids I want to become a
superhero just smack your wife around
because that's what happens every time
anything cool happens in like the media
gets a hold of it like some jackass
intern at CNN or MSN wherever it reads
what reads comics and he makes a
half-hearted reference he's like oh that
wife-beater is gonna be made into a
movie and then like some jackass and
editorials like oh what'd you say there
nerd wrong with that like ruin
everything god remember what Dark Knight
Rises was coming out and obviously
people had been heavily politicizing you
know what does Christopher Nolan mean
with this what he's trying to say yeah
and then rush [ __ ] limbaugh of all
people was like oh and the villain in
this movie is named Bane huh like Bain
Capital I'm just like no Raju rush
you're wrong about everything but you're
especially wrong if it's my uncle my
super conservative uncle called me on
the phone to ask me about that and I'm
like no no Bane existed
he's the loot no no no rush limbaugh is
wrong surprise I know how yeah right I
hate to tell you this
listen that crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] and
about stupid [ __ ]
feminists stupid what's happening over
on TV little house we are we got a hack
and splash page another great indie book
by Tiffany we just had our review of
Spider Girl our spider-gwen
should be called Spider Girl but it's
not it's called spider-gwen because
there's eight spider I know
so spider-gwen we reviewed that and a
bunch of other books on off-the-rack
just came out today on Thursday were
doing a new back issues of course every
week we do back issues and then over the
weekend we're leaving for pax
so we're going to do that and that's be
cool and then you know that we're coming
up on ten thousand subscribers and we're
planning a big fun episode we're gonna
do live stuff and it's gonna be cool you
know congratulations man that's thank
you so much
yeah yeah break watermelons like
Gallagher oh yeah naturally starts
smashing on the ground carrying on but
yes so um yeah like I'm doing okay so so
what I don't want to do is like this
road to conversions on the road to
secret wars and just like couple all the
stuff leading up to it so I always start
that maybe later on this week are
probably next week I'm not a hundred
cents sure we'll see what happens I also
need to write that I do guides for the
channel and I'm just like oh I should
have started that a month ago shouldn't
I feel like the kid who didn't hand in
his homework on time
look that's coming up isn't it free to
write it cuz I'm like put futures end
and worlds end is still going on and
these stuff might happen from that I
don't want to haven't written and done
only for something huge to happen nice
even thinking about it until I got New
Avengers number 30 and it's like in two
months time runs out I was like oh [ __ ]
it does does about Darkseid war guys the
other big DC event that no one is about
talking up a Darkseid war doesn't
darkside war feel like it should be the
big event yeah Darkseid super bad guy
hit me awesome nope like that kicked off
the new 52 and you think oh well he's
coming back well they've been building
up to this this should be the big things
in it but they're like now convergence
is where it's that no convergence which
we don't even know what the hell it is
yeah and it's like was Darkseid war
gonna get tie in just like it's not a
Batman book so now this is gonna be a
stretch now only Batman books gonna have
tie-ins anymore yep tried that with
Trinity war you people didn't like it so
now no more Justice League tie-ins ready
um have you guys seen the oh god what is
it oh the video but it's like this
parody video but it's like Kevin [ __ ]
doing an interview about about the about
Sony and spider-man and Marvel yeah
yeah it's just some like Spanish guy
with cat with uh with subtitles yeah but
it's it's hilarious man it is so funny
how awesome it to you on Twitter but
don't look that up now yeah it's it's
freakin hilarious like I thought I was
one of the funniest things I've ever
seen I can't stop laughing it was
hysterical but anyway yeah so um so
that's pretty much it I mean I have no
idea what Ben he's doing so he's taking
some time off he's got what yeah but
yeah guys so um we're to go ahead and
bring this episode of the podcast to an
end sounds good stop by the weekly pull
net Oh join up the with the forums we've
got a great board we got over 200
subscribers right now and it's a it's a
very and he's an active member it's
super great we're all on there we chat
it up we also got articles and videos
from like all over and it's a terrific
website check it out it's pretty badass
like a you guys would be good the forum
is insanely active like it is me up like
how active that is like people are all
over the place it's nuts it's fun on the
cannot go figure right what did you say
then like it's this amazing to me but
anyway so um so yeah I guess we're gonna
bounce off here we'll catch you guys
later alright peace